It's Halloween 2025 and Christians are
still keeping Halloween. Does that
surprise anyone else? Before Halloween
became what people think is harmless, it
was holy and horrific. A night of blood,
fire, and death, this was not a night of
fun. It was a ritualized interaction
with the dead, combining honor, fear,
and divination as people sought
protection and [music] knowledge before
winter's darkness. Sin is actually the
Celtic festival of the dead. It was the
New Year festival of the ancient Kelts,
[music]
beginning at sunset on October 31st and
ending at sunset on November 1st, the
midpoint between the autumn equinox and
the winter solstice. The Druids are the
occult priesthood of the Kelts, and they
performed rituals at sacred groves and
stone circles, invoking spirits and
gods, and druids would go house [music]
to house during sin or Halloween,
requesting food, livestock, or other
offerings. If the home complied, they'd
bless or pass it by. That's where you
the trick or treat type [music] of
thing. If not, they could curse the
home, market it for misfortune, or in
the darkest accounts, they would take a
person for the sacrifice. This offering
or curse type of system is considered by
some to be the origin of modern trickor
[music] treat. This is why people would
offer candy, pumpkins, or try to use
scare tactics like carved pumpkins and
jacko-lanterns to try to ward off
misfortune. Sometimes they used human
remains, but they would read omens
through animal intrails and have dreams
and fire they used for divination. Their
bonfires were massive fires where bones
of sacrificed animals and perhaps humans
were burned. They believe that unless
they offer human lives for human lives,
the will of the gods cannot be appeased.
While some modern neopagans whitewashed
the druids, early sources consistently
described them as sorcerers,
sacrificers, and necromancers, [music]
dangerous intermediaries between men and
demons. Sin marked a liinal time when
the barrier between the physical world
and the spirit realm was believed to be
the thinnest. Due to this, people
believed spirits of the dead and other
worldly beings could roam the earth.
Bonfires were lit to invoke or appease
these spirits, including deities of
death and chaos. [music] The fires also
served as purification and protection,
using parts of the year's harvest or
animals, as offerings. In the Wiccan and
neopagan cultures, sin is considered the
most sacred [music] Sabbath or Sabbath
on the wheel of the year. Is believed to
be a powerful time for [music] casting
spells, necromancy, and communication
with the dead. Rituals often invoke
chanting [music] and channeling spirits
performing sex magic or invoking the
horned god Sir Nunas, a masculine forest
deity who is eerily similar to Baffomet,
the satanic goat god or pan. Sin is
treated in occult circles as a ritual
gateway for spiritual contact,
especially with the dead or demonic
entities. When the Roman church couldn't
stamp out sin, they absorbed it and
rebranded it. In 731 AD, Pope Gregory
III moved All Saints Day to November 1st
to coincide with sin, [music]
baptizing paganism. October 31st became
All Hallow's Eve, eventually shortened
to Halloween. All souls day, which was
November 2nd, followed that, allowing
prayers for the dead on that day. Thus,
instead of cleansing pagan practices
from what was going to be called the
Christian church, instead married death
veneration and ancestor worship with
false Christian tradition. October 31st
in Luciferian rituals is quite the high
day within the church of Satan, the
temple of set and underground
Luciferians. They often mark October
31st as a major occult holiday. Why?
because the alignment with astrological
midpoints or crossquarter days. Power of
mass ritual is what they believe during
those times where the world unknowingly
practices and participates in death,
fear, and mockery of holiness. Many real
satanic rituals happen during the week
leading up to and following Halloween,
including animal and sexual sacrifices,
blood rituals, symbolic mockery of Jesus
[music] Christ, curses and hexes cast
during the thinning of the veil, and
many exacultists such as John Ramirez
[music]
and William Schnobble testify that
Halloween is one of the most powerful
satanic times of the year when curses
are released into homes that open their
doors to it. Did you hear that? While
the Bible never uses the name Halloween
or sin, it speaks bluntly to the spirit
behind it. Death veneration, spirit
contact, fear, blood sacrifices, and
dark ritual. God strictly forbids these
practices, not because they are
meaningless, [music]
but because they are real and
spiritually dangerous. Sin glorifies
what Christ came to conquer, death,
fear, and the powers of darkness.
Halloween may wear a costume of fun, but
underneath it mirrors the [music]
ancient systems of Babylon. Systems
built on deception, sacrifice, and
spiritual rebellion. Do not practice
divination or seek omens. Leviticus
19:26 says, "There shall not be found
among you [music] anyone who practices
divination, tells fortunes, interprets
omens, or is a sorcerer. For whoever
does these things is an abomination to
the Lord. Deuteronomy 18:10-12 [music]
says also from Revelation 2:8, which
says, "As for murderers, [music] the
sexually immoral sorcerers, their
portion will be in [music] the lake that
burns with fire and sulfur." Law
enforcement today actually has many
awareness guides which they pass out and
train [music] people with. Some of them
have titles like this, a cult
investigation manual for law
enforcement. They teach officers how to
recognize ritual [music] indicators at
crime scenes, altars, symbols, animal
mutilations,
body pieces, candles, and sigils. They
distinguish symbolism versus practical
motives such as thrillkilling, sexual
gratification, and revenge. It also
helps them understand what they call
calendar clustering, Halloween,
solstesses, equinoxes, because offenders
sometimes imitate these dates. Is that a
coincidence? Not at all. Each stresses
belief in a ritual motive, but tells us
that if there is belief in the ritual
motive, it does not equal proof of
organized Satanism. Instead,
investigators are told to document the
symbolism and treat it as context, not
the sole cause. Across these files, the
same pattern repeats itself, mixing sex,
power, and occult imagery such as robes,
candles, inscriptions. [music]
Occasionally on a Halloween week is what
they state, but more often than not, it
is always [music] during the Halloween
week. They range from animal mutilation
cases and [music] desecration of
churches or cemeteries to rare murders
where the offender claimed was a
sacrifice. Courts generally treat these
as homicide or sexual assault cases,
noting the ritual theme, but not
labeling them satanic [music]
networks. So, yes, police recognize that
ritual or occult style crimes [music] do
occur, that they often cluster around
Halloween season, [music] and that
investigators maintain reference guides
precisely for these cases. One cannot
make what is evil good and call good
evil. Yet this is what it has done,
including rights of Moolok and Canaan
and the Kelts of Druid Groves. You've
seen the truth. Now you're accountable
for it. [music] The veil has now been
lifted. What you do next determines
whether you stand with light and God or
slip back into darkness. [music]